i now introduce gibbs sampling
another randomized algorithm for motif
finding and gibbs sampling
works somewhat similarly to randomize
motif search the biggest difference is
that
randomized motif search is a rather
reckless algorithm
it can actually change all my found
motifs at
every iterations depending or to what
are profiled most probable k-mers
it is first it allows it to move very
quickly in the space of the solutions
but there is a danger that you already
came close to the correct motif
and then jump away from this because
randomized motif search
moves so fastly through the space of all
possible motifs
gibbs sampler is more conscious it
actually
changes at every step only one of the
chosen motifs
and the slide shows the key difference
between randomized motif search and gip
sampler
instead of showing you the pseudo code
for the gibbs sampler
let me show you first how it works
let's first select as before
motifs are shown in bolt at this slide
randomly in the set of dna strings as
before
blue elements showing planted motifs
and bolt element showed motifs random
materials that we selected
after we've done it let's do something
strange let's actually remove
one of the found motifs along with the
sequence it belongs to
in our example we remove third motif and
remove the third
dna sequence from consideration
so we'll consider the resulting set of
just for motifs
and build the count matrix based on this
set
and then afterwards construct profile
matrix
based on this count matrix and after we
constructed the profile matrix
we will calculate the probability of all
k-mers in the deleted string
afterwards we will do the following
again
relying heavily on rolling the dice
there are seven probabilities we
computed and we will
roll a seven sided dice according to
probabilities we computed it will be
heavily loaded by with this probability
of
sides proportional to the probabilities
that we computed
after we toss this we choose new
starting position
of the motif and proceed in this way
this is new substituted position
in the deleted sequence so that's how it
works
and then of course it iterates until
motifs keep improving
or until certain number of iterations
let's say hundred thousand iterations
so the outline of gibbs sampler we
randomly select
a k-mer in each sequence as before
we randomly choose one of selected
cameras from sequence
called sequence star and remove it from
the set of motifs
we create profile from the remaining
motifs
for each k-mer at the position i in
sequence
we compute its probability of being
generated by profile
resulting in n minus k plus 1
probabilities afterwards we generate
a coin with n minus k plus one
sides whose probabilities of sides
are proportional to probabilities we
computed
we roll this not coin by dice
and depending on the outcome of the dice
we return back this
motif number i to the sequence that we
remove
and we iterate so
let's once again look at how gibb
sampler work
let's assume that we've done the first
stages and we are about to generate
the probabilities of every k-mean in the
sequence i'm still considering the same
example
i considered before now we generated
our seven probabilities but now let's
pay attention
of what these probabilities are and it
turns out
that six out of seven probabilities
are actually zeros should we roll
a one-sided dice
four centuries ago oliver cromwell
warners against rolling one-sided dies
he told in his famous appeal to the
court of scotland
trying to convince them that their
alliance with the king was an error
he said i beseech you in the powers of
christ
think it possible that you may be
mistaken
chrome will rule in statistics imply
that the use of probabilities zero and
ones
should be avoided unless we talk about
purely logical statement thus
we should actually give a little
probability
even to extremely unlikely event for
example
we should give small probability to the
fact that
the sun won't rise tomorrow